[Applaudissements]
alors là et là c'est la nouveauté la
nouveauté nouveautés de camille combat
la nouveauté alors c'est simple je suis
descendu dans la rue en faisant passer
pour un journaliste un le tout
légèrement déguisée au cas où nous
reconnaissent même si c'est pas arrivé
depuis trois ans et je leur dis que j'ai
loupé une manif voilà que j'étais
journaliste j'ai loupé la manif et je
leur demande de me rendre ses relances
les gens sont très très sympa en faisant
jarry c'était dans cette manif qui
peuvent se débrouiller répondre à deux
questions et vous allez voir certains
sont meilleurs menteurs que d'autres on
a appelé ça a eu un gros brainstorm le
mytho trottoir en fait on avait la manif
des agriculteurs en la loupe on va se
faire défoncer
si on fait pas ça va être une galère ça
t'embête pas de questions je suis juste
ça va c'est passé il y avait du monde
tout ça et basta quoi hockey et dans les
rues de paris aujourd'hui pour cette
grande manifestation des agriculteurs
avec ludovic un qui faisait partie de ce
cortège
ludovic est ce que vos revendications
ont été obtenues eh ben on l'espère en
tout cas on était bien nombreux cette
fois ci on espère obtenir gain de cause
alors vous avez vous même une
exploitation sait dans quel domaine moi
je fais de la pomme de terre
on sait que les exploitations viticoles
sont à 0 3% de baisse
quelles seraient les mesures du côté
viticole que vous prendriez vous écoutez
moi je ne suis pas je sais pas ce qui se
passe dans le viticole moi je vous dis
c'est la terre la patate c'est vraiment
de questions en jouant juste ya eu du
monde ça s'est bien passé on voulait
juste jaloux parce qu'ils étaient tous
en blouse dans la manif un ça vous prend
de seconde dans les rues de paris pour
cette grande manifestation des
chirurgiens avec jérémy justement en
chirurgien orthopédiste qui est avec
nous bonjour jérémy alors est ce que
cette manifestation s'est bien passé ni
bien sûr grande mobilisation
oui beaucoup de monde la police dit 500
on parle plus de 1500 on doit entre les
deux je pense alors que pensez-vous du
conflit qui oppose aujourd'hui les
chirurgiens au centre hospitalier public
qui les oblige à reverser 3 % de leurs
honoraires
c'est un petit peu abusé toujours
donc vous vous êtes plutôt pour verser
ses honoraires non merci beaucoup à
jérémie s'il y avait un grand une grande
convention de bd avec que des fans de
bandes dessinées encore si tu es voilà
on est arrivé une heure trop tard si tu
peux nous arranger 2
je suis fait un des gars de bd ou alors
on a un petit recul mais ça fait genre
t'es tu sortais du truc chiant du truc
du genre tu sors du truc de bd je te
pose vraiment de questure bateau c'était
bien bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans les
rues de paris pour couvrir cette grande
manifestation des fans de comics et
c'est clément qui sort tout juste de la
convention et qui est le double de temps
torse et sa ruse alors que l'univers de
thor pour effet de faire le creeper
avant crédité à pour tout ce temps pour
eux merci clément
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]